dylan brooks with a dog of defense
against harden
screened by covington shot clock down to
seven for hard
now picked up by jaron who picked his
pocket earlier
and hardin puts in a three good job by
jaren i mean you you don't want to get
in a situation where you follow him on
that three and
no contact but contest jobs with the
acrobatic finish
and they've taken one shot inside the
yard and they've missed that that was by
westbrook here's a steal by morant
ja with numbers db angle triple try gets
down
and clark replaces valenciunis for the
grizzlies as we near the midway point of
the first quarter
pardon step back three that is his shot
one of the most proficient step back
shooters in the entire league
that's one area that clark is really
trying to work on his handle and his
ability to
work the perimeter hard down the lane
and harden with eight and a foul yeah
because they're starting whiteside and
nurkic together nifty pass valencian is
the finish great assist
from john morant his third to pull the
grizzlies
[Music]
westbrook backing down marant forced
that into a pass and then digging
at it there's 17 triples grizzlies had
just three
and harden loves to level you off and
he makes more step back jumpers than
anybody in the league making it
difficult for harden to get that space
that he can get with
such ease morant leaner
got that one to go with 2.4 odor to go
and then he gets this dunk to go as well
as jaren kind of
makes a space for jaw careful there 12.
now lost his boundary stumbling
no nearly put in a prayer
at the expiration of the shot clock
morant not to be denied
all the way to the top
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
morant for the lead
angelo had a phenomenal camp by all
reports
in orlando
[Music]
hardin with a drive and a finish is the
grizzlies working on certain lineups
it'll be interesting to see what tuesday
brings
morant hangs and hits john morant
putting together
a fantastic third quarter six to go
along with five rebounds for bc
hardened for three
fine by john moran late in the shot
clock here
good pass no hesitation from the anthony
who knocks it down
see if we can get a strong finish here
from the bench grizzlies down 10
and just kind of getting all out of
sorts now here in this fourth quarter
and harden with an exclamation point